[Musique]
vous donnez administrations fiscales en
millions sept cent cinquante mille euros
pouget payent pour les ménages moi je
suis au bout du monde
la courneuve y avait quand même c'est
après cela je sais pas il fait peur aux
vieux aussi là vous êtes maître chien
faisait peur des chiens non tenus cinq
minutes pour vous je vous présente
famille qui a la gentillesse de nous
limiter la grand mère selebi sané sami
vous devez avoir au moins quatre
nouvelles recrues dans la zone franche
pour les besoins de monde là et non pas
pour une bagarre pour du travail un but
et informatique ainsi qu'une technologie
génère une information qui secoue fait
du mal aux gens pour moi c'est la seule
qui m'ont pris en fait et on voit des
centaines de cv mais à part les stages à
retrouver bientôt on va comme qu'à
trouver du travail
les chemises jaunes verts magnifique
s'il avait 13 ans ils veulent pas me
suivre mais c'est pas de soucis face à
oui oui c'est très très grave
je sais pas d'où il vient c'est d'argent
quand tu vas à la banque toi tu demande
d'où vient le produit non fini s'il vous
plaît préfère ce sont là
d'abord quand on est arrivé ici on
pensait que ce serait compliqué enfin
moi je pensais que ce serait compliqué
et finalement c'est formidable
la cohabitation ça serait bien que juste
attention à pas laisser traîner nos
affaires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]